when you go to the bathroom you don't
want someone in there watching you not
because you're doing anything wrong but
because you want your privacy
we're here celebrating fourth july by
exercising our First Amendment rights in
order to protect our Fourth Amendment
rights in organizing the restore the
fourth rally we have talked to
libertarian groups you've talked to Tea
Party and Republican groups who talked
to democratic groups if you're an
American and you believe in the backbone
of America which is the Constitution
then then you believe in what the Fourth
Amendment has to stand for it's out here
today to protest at NSA prism all the
serbian savvy US government has been
implementing for a long time that's just
been one political warrior one single
institution it's a it's a slow decline
of just our rights in general my phone I
email my US mail just the last day or
two any time I go to a website my credit
card and he's spending I do hides all
that metadata is being tracked and
supported my analyst and from meditator
you got an awful lot of her it's just
wrong ideology or a party affiliation
let us be together united with one cause
joining this restore the fourth group
was worn out of Reddit and I've never
been politically active before but I
feel so so passionate about this issue
on a fundamental level and a lot of
people do no matter what their political
leanings no matter what their ideology
wouldn't matter if was Obama or Romney
or whoever and even if this
administration isn't abusing that power
who's to say the next one won't one of
the reasons that the Revolutionary War
was fought their forefathers shed blood
was to oppose the general warrants the
King George imposed on citizens of
colonies in the 18th century I'm a
citizen I get my fourth amendment right
I don't use it to hide my crime well I
use it because I'm an American yeah and
that's my right you want to have a panel
to reevaluate the constitutionality of
the u.s. Patriot Act specifically
section 215 and immediately repeal it I
found to be unconstitutional and restore
the checks and balances that have you
know kept our country safe for 200-plus
years and I think what NSA is doing is
this way just
everyone who's fought and died for
America this is this race